>> WELCOME BACK.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SPEAKING MORE
TODAY ON THE U.S. WITHDRAW FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
AND, OF COURSE, HE TOOK THE TIME
TO BLAME HIS PREDECESSOR.
>> THE UNITED STATES WILL DO OUR
PART, AND WE ARE ALREADY WORKING
CLOSELY WITH REFY ORGANIZATIONS
TO REBUILD A SYSTEM THAT WAS
PURPOSELY DESTROYED BY MY
PREDECESSOR.
>> SCINTILLATING.
THE REMAIN FOR NAVY SEAL POSTING
THIS BLUNT MESSAGE ON BIDEN ON
TAKING OWNERSHIP ON WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD BE TELLING
AMERICANS ABOUT AFGHANISTAN.
>> I MADE SOME CRITICAL ERRORS.
NAMELY, I UNDERESTIMATED THE
STRENGTH OF THE TALIBAN,
AMERICANS AND OUR ALLIES ARE ALL
STRANDED.
AND THAT IS MY FAULT.
BUT THEY WILL NOT BE STRANDED
FOR LONG.
WE WILL CONDUCT RAPID STRIKE
RESCUE MISSIONS UNTIL WE HAVE
RECOVERED AND EVACUATED ALL OUR
CITIZENS, ALLIES AND FRIENDS.
ANY PERSON THAT INTERFERES WITH
THESE OPERATIONS WILL BE KILLED.
>> YOU KNOW, THE BREAK JESSE YOU
WERE SAYING THAT YOU THINK YOU
COULD TAKE HIM.
YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THAT.
>> I'VE SAID A LOT OF THINGS IN
THE BREAK, GREG, NEVER THAT.
THAT WAS INSPIRING, THOUGH.
>> DO YOU HONESTLY BELIEVE THAT
A PRESIDENT WOULD EVER SAY
SOMETHING LIKE THAT?
>> NEVER.
>> POLITICIANS --
>> POLITICIANS COULD NEVER GIVE
THEIR POLITICAL OPPONENTS THAT
KIND OF AMMO AND ADMIT THAT THEY
WERE WRONG AND JOE BIDEN'S BEEN
IN DC HIS WHOLE LIFE, SO HE IS
PLAYING THE LONG GAME.
HE SEES THIS THING AS, LISTEN,
NOVEMBER'S AROUND THE CORNER,
THEN IT'S GOING TO BE WINTER,
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE THINKING
ABOUT COVID.
I'M GOING TO SEAL MYSELF, NOT
GET EMOTIONAL, GO OUT AND READ
THE TELL PROMPTER AND ALMOST
PSYCHOLOGICALLY CONVINCE MYSELF
THAT IT'S NOT AS BAD AS IT SEEMS
AND HE THINKS HE CAN GET THROUGH
THIS.
I DON'T THINK HE CAN GET THROUGH
THERE'S A HUGE DISCONNECT RIGHT
NOW BETWEEN THE PEOPLE AND THE
PRESIDENT AND HE'S LOST IT.
HE'S LOST CONTROL AND EVERYBODY
CAN SEE THAT NOW.
YOU SET A DEADLINE AT THE 31ST.
AND THEN HE SAYS, OH, YOU KNOW,
WE MIGHT HAVE TO MOVE THE
DEADLINE.
SO HE SENDS THE CIA DIRECTOR TO
KABUL TO NEGOTIATE EXTENDING THE
DEADLINE.
TALIBAN SAYS SCREWOFF.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO EXTEND THE
DEADLINE AND IF YOU EXTEND THE
DEADLINE WE WILL E START FIRING
ROUNDS AND BY THE WAY, FROM NOW
ON WE'RE NOT GOING TO LET
ANYMORE AFGANS REACH THE
AIRPORT.
JOE BIDEN SAYS OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP TO THE
DEADLINE.
HE'S BOXED HIMSELF IN.
>> YEP.
>> THERE ARE NO GOOD OPTIONS NOW
AND THAT'S HIS CALCULATION.
HE'S TRYING TO AVOID THE
SITUATION, WE HEARD JENNIFER
EXPLAIN THAT.
THAT'S NOT THE POINT.
EVEN ADAM SCHIFF LEFT THE
BRIEFING SAYING THERE'S NO WAY
WE CAN GET EVERYBODY OUT BY THE
DEADLINE, THOUSANDS WILL BE
TRAPPED AND POLITICO REPORTS
AMERICANS ARE ROUTINELY DENIED
ACCESS TO THE AIRPORT BY THE TAL
PAN.
A CA TAKES ROWER.
>> JENNIFER THIS IS TRULY A
CLUSTER RHYMES WITH TRUCK.
HOWEVER, I WANT TO STEAL MAN JOE
BIDEN TO YOU AND YOU TELL ME IF
THERE'S AN ANSWER TO THIS.
EVERYONE SEEMS TO HAVE THE RIGHT
ANSWER TO THIS PROBLEM EXCEPT
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION.
EVEN THE AVERAGE CAB DRIVER
GOES, HE GOT THIS BACKWARDS.
LIKE YOU DON'T HAVE THE TROOPS
LEAVE FIRST.
YOU DON'T ABANDON THE MOST
IMPORTANT AIR BASE.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THIS.
SO DID THEY ALREADY ENTERTAIN
THESE OPTIONS AND DECIDE, THIS
IS THE STEAL MAN PART OF IT,
THAT THIS WOULD BE THE LEAST
WORSE OPTION.
THAT IT COULD ACTUALLY BE WORSE
THAN THIS AND THEY JUST FIGURED
RIP THE BAND-AID OFF AND GET
EVERYBODY OUT?
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHY
THEY CHOSE THIS PATH.
>> I HOPE THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED
AND WE HAVE SEEN A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE FROM THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION CARRY OVER TO THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WHO HAVE
SAID THEY'RE REALLY UNHAPPY WITH
WHAT'S GOING ON.
VETERANS ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE, IF YOU WATCH LIKE SETH
BOWL TEN PRESENCE WHERE HE'S
APOPLECTIC ABOUT THE WORK GOING
ON AND THE WORK THE PEOPLE HE
COMMANDED PUT IN THIS PLACE.
OBVIOUSLY I HAVEN'T BEEN IN ANY
OF THESE ROOMS BUT MAYBE THIS IS
THE LEAST BAD OPTION.
OR SOMEONE SAID THAT.
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT WASN'T WHAT
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY SAID.
THAT WASN'T WHAT THE PEOPLE IN
THE MILITARY WERE SAYING.
SO THERE HAS TO BE SOME INNER
CIRCLE THAT IS OPERATING KIND OF
SEPARATED FROM THE NEXT LAYER OF
THE CIRCLE.
>> YEAH.
WOW.
>> AND THAT IS CONCERNING.
AND THERE'S SOMETHING TO JESSE'S
POINT ABOUT WHAT'S GOING TO GO
ON AND ELECTIONS ARE ALWAYS THE
THINGS THAT MATTER HERE.
A LOT OF PRESIDENTS MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT FOREIGN POLICY
THINGS THAT SAY THIS WILL BLOW,
IT IS A NOT HERE RIGHT?
AND THE WAY YOU CAN JUDGE
WHETHER THAT'S TRUE IS IF YOUR
CAB DRIVER KNOWS ABOUT IT, IF
THE PERSON WHO IS CHECKING YOU
OUT AT A GROCERY STORE -- NORMAL
PEOPLE.
AND EVERYBODY KNOWS ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON RIGHT HERE AND THEY'RE
ASKING QUESTIONS AND THEY'RE
WONDERING DID IT HAVE TO BE THIS
WAY.
THEY'RE NOT WONDERING SHOULD WE
LEAVE.
THEY'RE WONDERING DID IT HAVE TO
BE THIS WAY.
>> EXACTLY.
>> AND THAT'S THE KIND OF THING
THAT CAN STICK TO YOU OVER TIME.
>> IT IS A AS THOUGH DAGEN HE
SNATCHED DEFEAT FROM THE JAWS OF
VICTORY.
WE COULD HAVE LEFT AND REDEFINED
THE MISSION WHICH IS WHAT
JENNIFER WAS TALKING ABOUT WHICH
MAKES TOTAL SENSE.
>> JUST LIKE THE BOARD.
BIDEN BROKE SOMETHING THAT WAS
FIXED.
>> RIGHT.
>> I STARTED TALKING ABOUT THIS
ON DAY ONE.
WE WENT FROM AMERICA FIRST TO
AMERICA LAST, TO AMERICA OVER.
.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHO LEADS
WITH SHAME, NOT STRENGTH.
HE HAS TALKED OVER AND OVER
ABOUT THE SYSTEM, SYSTEMICALLY
RACIST UGLY BOY POISON OF THE
RACISM IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND WE TURN AROUND AND WHAT DO
WE DO?
WE KOWTOW AND GENUFLECT AND BOW
DOWN TO COUNTRY AFTER COUNTRY
THAT HATES US.
WE REJOINED THE PARIS ACCORD.
WHY?
DID THAT BENEFIT CENTER CITY NO,
BUT WE'RE ASHAMED OF ALL THE
FOSSIL FUELS THAT WE USE.
WE TRIED TO REOPEN NEGOTIATIONS
ABOUT THE IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL AT
THE SAME TIME YOU'RE TAKING A
HAMMER TO OUR ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE HERE?
AND THEN WE'VE HAD -- WE'VE SAT
BACK AND ALLOWED COUNTRIES LIKE
CHINA TO VOMIT THE WOKE LEFT
WING PABLUM OF THE MEDIA AND
THESE LIBERALS BACK IN OUR FACE.
TONY BLINKEN MET IN ALASKA IN
MARCH WITH A CHINESE OFFICIAL
AND THEY WERE -- HE WAS
LECTURING AMERICA ABOUT OUR SINS
AND THEN TONY BLINKEN, THE
SECRETARY OF STATE, THEN
APPROACHES THE UN ABOUT HAVING
THE HUMAN RIGHTS COUNCIL LECTURE
US ON SYSTEMIC RACISM.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE.
THEY ARE ASHAMED OF AMERICA.
RATHER THAN BEING PROUD, RATHER
THAN WORDS, MAY GOD BLESS
AMERICA AND MAY GOD HAVE MERCY
ON THE SOULS OF OUR ENEMY
BECAUSE WE WILL NOT.
JOE BIDEN IS ON THE RUN, 'CAUSE
HE'S ASHAMED.
>> YOU KNOW, I WONDER, DANA, DID
GENERAL MILLEY'S TAKE ON WHITE
RAGE, IS THAT GOING TO HELP WITH
THE TALIBAN.
>> IT WILL NOT.
>> I DIDN'T THINK SO.
>> I CAN ANSWER THAT.
GENERAL KEANE SAID SOMETHING ON
AIR ABOUT A WEEK AGO.
HE SAID HIS ENTIRE CAREER
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS BEEN
RELENTLESSLY STUBBORN SO THAT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY HE WOULD
NEVER SAY WHAT JACK 0 WAS
SUGGESTING BUT THERE IS ONE
PRESIDENT WHO, VERY HARD THING
TO DO AND TO BRING TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND IS EXTREMELY
UNPOPULAR AND EVENTUALLY IT
WORKED AND THAT WAS WHEN
PRESIDENT BUSH DID THE SURGE.
TALK ABOUT UNPOPULAR TO SAY
ACTUALLY, WE HAD PROBLEMS, WE'VE
MADE MISTAKES AND WE NEED TO
SEND MORE TROOPS IN.
AND NOT EVEN -- EVEN THE CABINET
WAS LIKE OH, NO, WE'RE NOT.
AND IT TOOK SEVERAL MONTHS BUT
WE -- A COUPLE OF MONTHS FOR
PRESIDENT BUSH AND THE GENERAL
TO CONVINCE THE NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL THAT THIS WAS
THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
EVENTUALLY IT ENDS UP THAT IT
WAS THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
SO THERE IS A WAY TO DO THIS.
AND THE OTHER THING IS, I DO
THINK AMERICANS UNDERSTAND RISK
AND THEY CAN HANDLE RISK.
THEY CAN HANDLE THE TRUTH.
SO IF THERE WERE TO BE SOMETHING
LIKE WHAT JACCO SUGGESTED, WE'RE
GOING IN THERE AND GOING TO GET
OUR PEOPLE, IF YOU SAY, THERE
MIGHT BE SOME CASUALTIES AND
WE'RE GOING TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN, I JUST
WANT TO PREPARE YOU FOR WHAT
COULD HAPPEN, AMERICANS CAN
ACCEPT THAT.
BUT I THINK WHAT THEY CAN'T
ACCEPT IS THIS, AND I THINK YOU
SEE IT IN THE NUMBERS.
THE USA TODAY POLL THAT CAME OUT
TODAY, HAS THE PRESIDENT AT 41%
APPROVAL TOTAL.
ONLY 32% OF INDEPENDENCE APPROVE
OF THE JOB HE'S DOING.
THAT NUMBER HAS DROPPED BY LIKE
30 POINTS IN JUST THE PAST FEW
MONTHS.
AND I THINK THAT IT'S ONLY
TUESDAY.
I IMAGINE HE'LL BE IN THE 30s BY
THE WEEKEN